[Music]
Hannity were broadcasting live we are in
Las Vegas tonight joining us now Tony
weird itis is with us his wife Denise
died in his arms Sunday night after the
government opened fired also with us is
Kellie Huff and her daughter Cassidy
Huff Cassidy battling cancer finished
chemo treatments just prior to attending
the concert the other night as she was
running she was helped off by police off
duty officers when she became too weak
to run after the shooting started by the
way thank you all all for being with us
really really appreciate it
Tony I married 32 years two years and
you have two kids tell us what happened
your wife died in your arms 32 years
every day was better two kids and four
grandchildren and the fifth one was on
the way I wanna I want the world to know
Denise she had a beautiful smile and and
she was a great person loved her
grandchildren we were at the concert and
is that what you from the concert we
initially heard the first round at Bert
gun fire didn't think it was gunfire she
actually asked me and I told her no the
second round started and I knew it was I
grabbed her by the hand Troutman post
was she - you wouldn't this have to
choose right at me and next day we were
holding holding hands and when she was
struck she was she was behind me I
turned and was struck in the head yes
it's unfathomable to me I mean we had
John Rich on the program kya Jones they
were up stage number god bless america
absolutely about an hour before agree
unbelievable how's your family now
they're doing well we all have our ups
and downs but they're doing well they've
supporting one another back home and
we're ready to get get Denise home and
and let everything start to heal
I'm so sorry thank you I'm so sorry for
all that you're going through and all
that you've been through Cassidy you're
a young woman you just finished your
last chemo when it was in August the
first week of school and you just
beginning to feel better yeah and the
concert was a big deal to you you've
been there before I think or so the
shooting breaks out obviously chemo
weakens everybody tell us what happened
you started running yeah we started
running trying to beat the crowd and it
was very scary because I didn't want to
get trampled because I were so weak and
my mom lifted me up through like a some
type of pretzel stand or something and
and then we ran from there but like a
bad dream where you can't you want to
run so fast but you can't because my
legs just wouldn't let me you still
recovering I mean you've been through a
very tough treatment and I know people
home will want to know you do have a
pretty good prognosis right now yeah and
so far scans are clean mom a bunch of
people came over to your daughter I'm
calling you mom and Kelly I'm sorry but
you're off-duty police officers it's
tough to carry a kid tell us what they
did for your daughter well as soon as we
had crossed the street initially she
basically collapsed behind a car and
just gonna go and before I could think
about what to do an LAPD officer just
scooped her up and said keep running and
his girlfriend grabbed my hand and we
continued to run and take cover between
behind another dumpster
long beach officers then need us just
they didn't know each other they menace
is also behind that car and then asked
us to keep running and he told his wife
just get the car and take us home and
come back for him later we were home by
11:15 which is a miracle did you get a
chance to talk to him again no I haven't
talked to them yet my parents have it's
very hard I guess for all of you you
know here we are on TV I do four four
hours on air a day the country races
into a big debate over gun control you
lost your wife when you hear that and
then maybe juxtapose a person's what the
president said today what is the right
thing for the country to do and how to
handle it it was it was a tragedy Sunday
night I still will never give up my
rights
still never give up my rights you know
and that's the thing when something's
happening you want those officers you
want if it's a close-quarters situation
like San Bernardino or and they drop
their clip or any of these other
instances in schools where they've done
it you know if there's somebody there
they can help amazing people listen what
do you want to be when you get older I
want to be a pediatric nurse you
inspired by the nurses that yeah all
right you're in our prayers god bless
you okay thank you for coming by
our thoughts and prayers I'm so sorry I
really have just a the world to know
Denise and and and there her smile if
you haven't seen it yet you need to find
it
32 years 32 years and prayers are with
your family and your grandkids and your
children ma'am this is a special girl
all right god bless you all we
appreciate it when we come